apple's november 10th mac event just
finished
and let me tell you guys i am blown away
by the numbers that apple gave us
and i'm extremely excited because we've
already ordered
four of these new macs we got one
macbook air
two macbook pros both of the models and
the mac
mini so if you guys want to see all of
our in-depth testing and comparison
videos
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out and please help us reach our goal of
500k
subs by the end of the year now most of
you guys out there are probably only
going to order
one of these new apple silicon macs and
with them being
available to order right now it's a
really tough choice to make
but if you watch this full video all the
way to the end
i'm confident that you'll make up your
mind so before we get into the buyer's
guide portion of this video
let's talk about the eight mistakes you
should avoid
when buying your new apple silicon mac
for avoiding mistake
number one be sure to buy the amount of
memory that you need out of the gate
because it is no longer user replaceable
on
the mac mini like it used to be just
like it is
on the macbooks so if you think you'll
be doing productivity work
you should probably go for 16 gigs of
memory for another 200
now for mistake number two don't think
that you have to pay
apple's premium for these storage
upgrades
since all of these macs come with
thunderbolt 4 ports
you can buy super fast external ssds
like the 2 terabyte sabrand xtreme q
which is our favorite ssd ever for only
360 dollars
compared to 800 for apple's two terabyte
storage
upgrade however be very cautious because
you can actually make mistake number
three
if you're not careful all of these new
apple silicon macs only have
two thunderbolt ports even the mac mini
which used to come with four and the
best external ssds
use one of those thunderbolt ports and
on top of that
the mac mini no longer has the option of
upgrading to
a 10 gigabit ethernet port so you'll
have to use an adapter if you want that
which takes up another one of those
thunderbolt ports
and same thing for those who want to
connect to a thunderbolt display
so if you know you might be using those
two ports it'll be a good idea to
actually pay
for internal storage for mistake number
four
if you're thinking of playing games or
doing productivity work on your new
apple silicon mac
it may be a bad idea to go for the
macbook air
because it comes with a completely
fanless design
because of that longer workflows that
use the graphics
like playing high-end games like gentian
impact
could cause it to gradually heat up over
time
and there's a chance it could throttle
down the power since we don't know how
good the thermal performance
is just yet but we're definitely going
to be testing it out
in those cases it'll definitely be a
better idea
to go for the macbook pro or the mac
mini which both come with a cooling fan
however be sure to avoid mistake number
five
because if you're mainly going to be
browsing the web and using common apps
the macbook air is the best choice
because it's going to be completely
silent
all the time and those common tasks
won't cause it to heat up that much
so a lot of the iphone and ipad apps
that we can now
finally run on any of the new apple
silicon macs
should run nice and cool on the macbook
air
and even things like photo editing or
other workflows that require
short bursts of power should be fine
with the fanless design
now that actually brings us to mistake
number six
don't think you have to buy the macbook
pro if you want the best performance
you can actually get the same exact m1
chip with all the cores enabled on the
air if you want to
and the less expensive mac mini as well
and if your work
happens in short bursts you shouldn't
see any throttling due to heat
on top of that the air now has the same
color accuracy as the pro
finally getting p3 wide color gamut
support
so it's perfect for photo editing now
mistake number seven
is probably one that you're not
expecting if you want the best
battery life in any macbook the air is
no longer the one to buy
in previous years the air used to have
two hours more battery life
compared to all of the other macbooks
but now it's
actually flipped because the macbook pro
has a larger battery and it uses the
same chip
it now gets up to 17 hours of web
browsing battery life
that's two hours more compared to the
air
and that's actually a massive seven
hours more
than the previous 2020 intel macbook pro
which is absolutely incredible and
finally for mistake number eight
while the mac mini looks like an
excellent deal at just
hundred dollars keep in mind that it
doesn't come with a display
or a mouse or a keyboard and by the time
you buy all those other things
especially a decent color accurate
display
you could end up over the 1 000 price of
the macbook air
so keep that in mind now with all of
those mistakes out of the way
let's get into exactly who should be
buying each one of these new apple
silicon macs
if you want the absolute least expensive
mac there is out there
the mac mini is the one to buy and the
new apple silicon chip is gonna make it
perform
incredibly well compared to other
desktop pcs
the mac mini is perfect for those who
already have a mouse a keyboard
and a display on hand so it ends up
being a much less expensive option
this is also great for photo editors who
may already have a very nice and
expensive
color accurate display and maybe even an
hdr
display which you don't get with the
macbooks so this will make it a
killer mac for video editing as well
since you have the fan to keep it cool
and the m1 chip gives you so much
graphics performance
but on the flip side it's a great choice
for the regular joe
who just wants a reliable computer and
at seven hundred dollars it's probably
the best choice you can make
if you want to replace an old windows
desktop computer
that's starting to slow down due to
virus issues
and other things like that the mac mini
won't have any of these
issues especially now that the m1 chip
gives you even better security and
reliability
and you get the added bonus of
up-to-date specs like wi-fi 6
bluetooth 5.0 and on top of that all of
these new macs have the ability to run
iphone and ipad apps which is going to
be incredible
now of course not everybody wants to be
limited to a desktop computer
so let's get right into the new macbooks
which you can take on the go
starting with the new air at a starting
price of 999 dollars
it's going to be extremely popular since
this is going to be the most reliable
macbook air
that apple has ever created the
combination of the price tag
the reliability the quick and snappy
performance of the m1 chip
and the completely fanless design makes
it the best
choice for people working from home this
includes everything from
web browsing streaming video being on
zoom calls with
absolutely no fan noise using document
apps like word
excel and business apps as well
the air is perfect for all of those
things
and it'll even satisfy the needs of
those who like to occasionally use
performance apps
like some video and photo editing and
it's actually the absolute best choice
for students as well
since you can get it for only 899
and it's by far the most portable
macbook that apple has to offer
giving students everything they need for
their school
work and they can play some casual
iphone and ipad games on the side
if they'd like to as well now the
macbook pro is for those who want
long-standing extended performance on
the go
the base 1300 model comes with the eight
core graphics
right out of the gate unlike the macbook
air so it's the best choice
for those needing graphics performance
this makes it perfect
for things like video editing since the
fan is going to keep it cool
while editing 8k prores video like apple
showed off during the event
and for high-end users like that i would
definitely recommend going for 16
gigabytes of memory
the built-in fan also makes the macbook
pro the best choice for gamers
since you know that it'll stay cool
during extended gaming sessions
especially for higher-end competitive
games like call of duty mobile
which you should be able to play using a
controller or even games like gentian
impact or anything coming in the future
like league of legends
wild rift the pro also gets some extra
bonus features
like the built-in touch bar a larger
track pad
a brighter 500 nit display compared to
400 on the air
studio quality microphones better
speakers with high dynamic range
a larger 61 watt power brick compared to
30 on the air
and of course an extra two hours of
battery life
and for a lot of people those things are
definitely worth
the extra three hundred dollars compared
to the air so
there you guys go hopefully this video
helps you make a decision
on which apple silicon mac to buy and if
it did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe because we're getting those
macs in
next week but if you're still confused
go ahead and leave a comment below and
i'm gonna help you out with your
specific situation
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
stop hang on wait uh one more thing hi
i'm fec i'm fast i'm still fast check it
out